el pescador tony fernando vuelve a
puerto arrastrado por un tractor a una
hora de lisboa no hay muelle ni ninguna
otra infraestructura los barcos se
arrastran por la arena y se quedan al
sol es un trabajo agotador ahora es de
extrañar que estos pescadores reclamen
un muelle en condiciones en este
contexto las elecciones no entusiasman a
estos trabajadores algunos de los
pescadores consideran que los partidos
políticos han ignorado al sector durante
demasiado tiempo son todos iguales solo
quieren nuestros votos pero una vez
pasadas las elecciones seguirán como
hasta ahora partidos políticos como el
ultraderechista checas se están
vendiendo como una fuerza que defenderá
a los pescadores sus movimientos
recuerdan a la extrema derecha global
posicionados en la tradición mientras el
líder del partido llegó a pedir la
deportación de una diputada afro de
izquierdas siempre sports todo en que
los puertos no son suficientemente
buenos no responden a las necesidades
actuales también necesitamos nuevos
barcos más adecuados para la pesca
tradicional
desde el gobierno han querido reaccionar
y el primer ministro socialista antonio
acosta visitó los puertos del país el
empate técnico que arrojan las encuestas
han hecho que todos buscan el voto
diferencia al pesquero incluso el
partido comunista este diputado nos
llevó a comprobar el abandono del puerto
de lisboa
en desembarcar pescado en ese puerto
porque el punto de venta está cerrado el
gobierno portugués en los últimos años
se que enmarcado en las políticas
comunes de pesca en la unión europea
podría haber ido más lejos y de opinión
los expertos advierten de que si no
mejoran considerablemente las
condiciones de trabajo la pesca
tradicional desaparecerá ya que los
jóvenes se elegirán otros medios de vida
mientras los pescadores de portugal
tienen una media de 45 años